[Music]
hallo YouTube just loves in my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the 47th
episode of dirty chest tricks in this
episode you are going to see a wonderful
trick and a high profile trap in the
Portuguese or the Judoon gambit the
interesting part is recently Carson used
this line in pro chess leak to beat
indian grandmaster of a bursary and if a
2600 strength grandmaster can fall for
this then certainly your opponent can
been expecting the opening arises after
the following modern evil defy he kept
his g5 and now the modern Scandinavian
variation Knight to f6 so blacks big
idea is he wants to take back the pawn
with Knight and accordingly the
mainlines continues with d4 so what
white is aiming that after black
captured with the night then he can play
the moon seafood and grab every single
space in the center of the board okay
but instead of routinely capturing the
d5 pawn black's idea is more potent he
want to play this move Bishop to g4
attacking the Queen and gambit in the d5
pawn here a fight continues with either
the move Knight to f3 or Bishop to e2
there I think black get a playable
position so the only way to get
advantage as a white why it has to
continue with f3 counter attacking the
bishop which in fact white played in
this game Bishop to fi and now here
white has two choices Bishop to b5 check
and the second-highest popular choice
namely c4 so idea is very simple white
wants to be greedy and consolidate his
extra pawn after this black should play
a true gambit style and accordingly he
6mu is a fitting reply D captures c6
maintaining the good center and you
might think okay black will capture with
Bishop or that pawn but here comes the
super surprise black more or less
doesn't care about the pawns he's
speeding ahead with his piece
development
Knight to c6 here if I'd continued with
defy the knight to be four is a very
strong reply but it is very obvious that
white is not going to miss this check he
captures f7 and after King takes f7 at
least white can argue that he has
misplaced black ink and on top he's a
clear pawn up so what can be the better
than that well as the game progressed we
are going to see the vital point behind
the new king to have seven right now
black has attacked the d4 pawn and there
are two ways white can't defend this
pawn the first move d5 which is in fact
an inaccuracy by white as a simple
continuation Knight to be four gives
black a great attacking position a
sample line can run like this night to
e3 defending c2 Bishop to c5 so
permanently stopping white to castle on
the Kings side and rook to e8 is coming
in the picture very fast and if white
continue with Bishop to e2 then rook to
e8 will happen anyways
there's a one quick game in the database
will finished just within 12 moves and
here white made the ultimate error
Bishop to d2 trying to get rid of the
knight but what he missed is after
Knight to b3 check King to have fun and
night to f2 White has a disgusting
position so accordingly Bishop to e3 is
a most popular choice by white
afterwards black will continue with this
sneaky check and here it doesn't matter
whether white continued with King to f2
or Knight to c3 the line will be
transposed let's say in this game
white continued 8 Knight to c3 and after
rook to e8 attacking on the bishop white
has the only good reply namely King to
f2 protecting that bishop and what white
is dreaming is OK time being I am behind
in development but I have a wonderful
Center and as my PCs are going to come
out my position will surely improve now
we reach to the critical position of
this line and if you check in online
database you will find out that there
are more than 100 games played from this
position where black winning ratio is
tremendous before I move on I like you
to pause this video and find out I
besides a sequence or the move which
create the death knell for the white
camp ok the poisonous sequence start
with this decisive move oh so this
the defender of the d4 square and
drawing white King in the center of the
board well now comes the second step and
this is most important how we can
exploit this keying and before I move on
I like you to pause second time and find
out a moon which in fact instantly kill
the white take your time because this
move is one of the wonderful move in
this line well if you believe it or not
but even Carlson didn't find this move
in his game he continued with night
captures d4 which is in fact the third
base choice of the engine one of my
friend recently played a free day to
Naaman and he has a strength of 2,000
they faced an opponent which has around
1600 rating and he reached the same
position thinking that there is not much
going on in the position but his
opponent played the top move of the
engine which literally shake him off let
me just show you this move Bishop to see
to take a timeout and look at how PT
able white position is after this moon
haha my friend here thought for 30
minutes and couldn't find a solution for
the white camp this simple move Bishop
to c2 is a deflection move for the Queen
so that if the Queen captured the bishop
or go somewhere else where she can no
longer protect the d4 pawn let's say
Queen - even then the simplest move is
Queen captures before and after King to
e2 and Bishop to c5 the mate is
unavoidable for the white
and I just like to show you this game
because how entertaining
the finish is my friend continue with
the obvious move Queen to d2 staying in
protection of the default pawn but then
he kept this rude shock ahahaha
so this decisive blow confirms that
black will have all the fun and white
King will literally do a moonwalk
towards the black camper
well obviously you cannot take this 9
the simple reason is after Queen to GFI
check King to e2 and now rook to e8 at
lease that Queen is a goner
so that's not a good choice for the
white that means White King has to come
forward King to f4 okay guys let's get
ready this is the final time I'm asking
you to pause this video and find out how
you are going to finish off white I'll
give you a hint there is a mate in fire
on the border are you ready let's get
started
the first move is very obvious Bishop to
d6 check King captures g4 now comes the
second death link sacrifice fish up to a
fat check if King to H fire than g6
leads to the mate so white has to accept
this P sacrifice afterwards the most
critical moment of the game and many
people miss this the third and the most
important move and this position is
Queen to h4 stopping any backpedal for
the white king and now black has a
simple threat g6 checkmating white king
here it doesn't matter whether white
continue with f4 or G for let's say g4
but against each of them black response
is very obvious rook to e8 cutting down
all the hope for the white and the most
amazing part about this position is
there are three ways black can checkmate
wai-king and white doesn't have a single
check available in this position that's
it guys I hope you enjoy and learn this
wonderful line of the jaw dual gambit
which you definitely want to consider in
your own tournament game remember once
you reach this position play this super
surprising move Bishop to c2 and after
this it is only Viking who is fighting
for the survival well thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment on this and I'll
meet you in my next episode very soon
bye and take care